so let's hop on the DNA analysis thing
um so Dr J did mine the first time but
we didn't do the full 90 minute deep
dive and we kind of breezed over it at
20 000 feet one of the things he said
he's like you know there's some things
here that if you really want to get into
we can get into them but it's probably
not you know something you want to talk
about for 90 minutes on your show and
get in all those details but I found it
dude it's unbelie like this this this
300 that you can spend with Dr J to get
your DNA analyzed is probably the best
300 bucks you can spend from a starting
point for Health Nutrition sleep and all
these different things because a lot of
people will be like oh I watched this
guy on YouTuber I heard this podcast and
he said well you have to sleep at this
time or you have to wear these glasses
at this time or do that at that time or
eat these Foods eat loads of avocados
don't eat loads of these sort of things
it's like that might work for you but it
may not work for me depending on how my
DNA is structured mine's different from
yours right so here's what I found when
I did mine so
um I've got this rare Gene which doesn't
allow me to process plant cholesterols
and so my system gets like basically
backed up and bunged up anything seeds
uh nuts
um seed oils like anything that's got
fat in it that comes from a plant my
body can't process it so it just blocks
on my system you get some inflammation
out of it surprisingly my inflammation
markers and my blood labs are actually
pretty low so everything else I'm doing
seems to try to neutralize it but
neutralizing it isn't optimal right
no
um so that was the first thing so plant
cholesterols was a huge detriment I've
cleaned them out of my diet I used to
eat like two avocados a day and he's
like avocados are like Kryptonite for
you dude you have to stop eating them
I'm like okay I didn't know that right
so you know you start there and you
start looking at other parts of your DNA
and like my mom's cultural side of the
family is is Greek but they're really
Italian
um according to the source code and then
my dad's side of the family is broadly
Northwestern European so you can kind of
read like you know Viking so whatever
DNA I got myself it's basically from
family members that ate a lot of meat
and my system's good with me people will
tell you you know you can't eat meat
your cholesterol is going to go through
blah blah blah I can't eat fatty plants
like that [__] me up way more than
anything else so again like you can't
follow somebody's diet because they say
just be a vegan or just be a military or
whatever it's like dude for 300 bucks
you can find out exactly what your
ancestors have been eating and exactly
what your body process is and can't
process right what was your experience
experience with Dr J when you did yours
first off man it's an honor always be
here with you I appreciate you grateful
uh and talk to your audience too I've
gotten so many great emails and messages
from all the people that follow you over
the year so again bro appreciate you
love you I'm always grateful to be here
with you and and to talk to you
um and you do have an amazing audience
and you know Anthony
but after I introduced him to you you
know I was like dude Richard's the man
I'm like yeah bro all my people are cool
but uh so I worked with Dr J we did four
webinars back from I think the last
webinar we actually did was right before
the scandemic but we did like four
webinars from 2000 end of 2018 to early
I'm sorry late 2019 and they were all
profound you know I have them all we did
the metabolism we did the brain
um you know and I'll I'll tell you this
you know I know you know this but your
audience might not I mean Dr J
was the guy who decoded
gynecomastia for men is genetic
there wasn't a single surgeon on the
planet that was performing gyno surgical
you know excisions or removals
you know until Dr J decoded this and I
was kind of playing Just for people that
don't know what that is yeah so
gynecomastia is literally 64 of all men
in the world have gynecomastia meaning
they have the gene they code for the
codon when Anthony looks at your genes
for uh tissue that grows outside of the
male breast that becomes like fatty
tissue or almost like a tumor now I have
that Gene and in 2016 I had gyno from my
right nipple removed and I had the
Worlds at the time leading gynecomastic
surgeon Who's down in Newport Beach
California Dr Joseph Cruz
and he at that time didn't know that it
was genetic and he had already performed
you know 4 400 surgeries at the time now
fast forward to now he's performed like
15 000 surgeries I blew him up I did all
sorts of interviews and podcasts with
him and stuff like that and then you
know he found out through Dr J in 2018
about all this and so you know he became
even deeper into this but Dr J you know
I tell people this because uh as you
said Dr J is a very underrated person
like his his technology is probably as
good as anything out there and I
actually have gone out on a record you
know agree in agreeing with you been
taking it further like I don't believe
if you're a hormone optimization clinic
or a longevity clinic or whatever you
want to call it health optimization
Clinic you should incorporate his
diagnostic testing before any of your
patients start anything because he can
look at your polymorphisms which are
essentially you know like you said the
genetic fault or the genetic you know
potential genetic false that you're
going to feel so if you're a guy for
example that is a what is called a hyper
excretor as a if you use testosterone
and you're a hyper excretor you're going
to have specific issues
um in if you inject your testosterone
versus if you use a transdermal delivery
system so there's all these little
nuanced things that people don't know
you know getting back to what you were
saying about taking diet you know using
diets or specific diets or supplements
if you don't know these things there's
no way you can actually find out unless
you suffer you know most of the time
through the experiences of of dealing
with that you know for example again the
gyno Gene I also have uh the gene for
like I can take massive amounts of
caffeine
stimulants uppers any of that stuff and
it doesn't affect me whereas like
somebody else and one of you know one of
the peptide drugs we're going to talk
about today is Tessa fencing if you're
sensitive to that which is the opposite
of what my codon says um you can't even
handle a small dose of Tesla fencing
because you're going to lay on your bed
staring at the ceiling at night you know
unable to go to sleep so all these
sensitivities he reads in your DNA and
he can decode these things for you so
that you can then take it to your
physician or whoever you're working with
if and you're into this things that you
and I are into that will prevent you
from experiencing these horrible things
you know a good friend of mine Dr Rob
komenarik I should probably have him
have you and him talk too he's a great
guy in Dayton you know he works with a
lot of celebrities and stuff great great
hormone observation doctor doing this
for 23 years
he talks about how like certain guys
have this weird polymorphism where if
they stay if they take injectable
testosterone within 24 to 36 hours bro
they have panic attacks really like he
literally knows a guy who was a CEO of a
very large corporation who was his
client who he didn't have my
testosterone for his first couple of
years because he attempted to do
everything naturally he eventually put
him on and the guy's wife called one
morning and said uh my husband is
underneath his our bed
in the bedroom right now and he doesn't
know what to do and he's in a panic he
said to call you so I mean these are the
kind of things that like Anthony can
read but again if you're ignorant and
you're not doing these tests and like
you said it's the easiest 300 that
you'll ever spend because he'll sit down
as you know and he walks you through I
think a lot of guys did you know this
because you've done lab work I mean
you've helped guys try to get labs and
stuff done a lot of people have an
apprehension to doing some of these
things because they they kind of say
well [__] I don't know how to read it
you know what am I going to do I'm not
Richard's not going to read it for me
Jay's not going to read it for me like
what am I going to do so then they just
like decline it but it's like Dr J he
sits down with you and he goes through
it all with you you know so it's totally
worth it
yeah
um you know like I said earlier the best
300 bucks you can spend I mean people
spend that kind of money on
pills or powders or or proteins and it's
like fine I mean you could be spending
loads and loads of money on like whey
protein for example and find out your
DNA allergic to it yeah yeah it just
doesn't accept it so bro I never could I
never could drink protein I figured that
out when I was young I was always
lactose intolerant I could drink milk up
until I was 24.
and again nobody knew any of this stuff
and then we found out that like a lot of
adults lose that enzyme to digest
lactose yeah yeah so you can't even eat
way yeah yeah no it's it's no it's just
Bonkers like the amount of data that
comes off it like the way that it works
so you guys understand and Dr J's link
for his DNA analysis is pinned in the
description of this video
um the way that it works is you get your
raw code from 23andMe or ancestry
um I don't know what that costs like 80
bucks or something like that you can
probably get like 50 bucks yeah
something yeah like you can get a coupon
somewhere probably online to get it for
less or you know Black Friday sales or
whatever but um you know so you go get
that and then it you know you get an
email or like a little diagram in your
app and it says oh you know you're 23
from this part of the world and 17 from
this part of the world and it's like
fine whatever you know like that might
be a little bit interesting for some
people but the raw code that you can
download that they get from the the DNA
code they get from your salon is what Dr
J runs through his algorithm and then
he'll give you this email with a
printout that mine was like a dozen
pages long and and it's got all these
genetic
um anomalies that you'll have in your
system that are similar to some people
and very very different from other
people and you'll spend 90 minutes on a
private consult and tell you exactly
what everything means what it means for
supplementation what you should be
supplementing with what you should stay
away from what you should take out of
your diet what you should add to your
diet if you have any predispositions for
a heart disease dementia Alzheimer's all
of these things show up in your DNA code
right so if you've had family members
that have had like gallbladder issues or
they've had Alzheimer's there's there's
things that he can guide you on you know
on a path that will either stop that
from happening or minimize the effects
of it happening
um so again you know I really encourage
you guys to take a look at that it was
it was like I've spent a lot of money
I have everything I have I have the
cooling mat under my mattress like
everything like I've done it all right
this was probably the cheapest and the
most effective thing that I've done so
it is he's probably gonna jack up his
prices because he's going to get so busy
after this podcast so I'd grab it now
it's like 300 bucks it's like 50 off so
that Link's below super super useful
information if you want to know more
about Dr J I would go back to my other
two podcasts that I did with him on the
plane to win Series where we were
talking about his book Esther generation
and the second one it's we're still
touching on the topic of environmental
estrogens and how they affect you plus
some stuff on cholesterol so go look at
those I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out